The School of Life has always felt very close
to the German language in general - and to
Switzerland in particular.
That’s why we’re so pleased to announce
that we are at last coming to Zurich, with
a big 3 day conference that we’re going
to be running starting on Friday, 12th of
October, 2018.
Taking place in Zurich’s university of the
arts, this is a three day event about everything
we care about at the School of Life: emotional
intelligence, wisdom, self-understanding,
love, friendship and meaning.
The conference will mirror what happened in
our conferences in Lisbon Portugal in October
2017 and San Francisco, USA in March 2018.
That means we’ll have lectures in the day,
great meals together, the best kinds of interactions,
and chats about everything that matters late
into the night. It’ll be a true chance to
experience a globally-minded community dedicated
to learning, kindness, self-exploration and
wisdom.
The conference lasts three days and is led
by our founder and creative lead, Alain de
Botton - and will feature our best teachers,
and our very best, and most transformative
ideas.
If you’re interested in coming to Zurich
to meet us in October, please click on the
link on the screen now.
You’ll learn a lot - return with a huge
number of useful new ideas and make friends
for life.
We hope to see you there.